[Musique]
l'univers n'a pas toujours été comme ça
nous savons aujourd'hui
à l'origine il y avait un oeuf cosmique
concentré de masse atomique qu'après
ont atteint la limite de densité
Il y a 15 milliards d'années, il a explosé
jetant ses fragments dans l'espace
certains de ces fragments subsistent
incandescent et formé les étoiles
d'autres se sont refroidis et ont
ont formé les planètes et les météorites
voyageant dans l'espace ces éclats
ils ont fini par former le nombre
inimaginable de 10 au onzième de
galaxies qui composent l'univers
l'univers est si gigantesque que
notre galaxie la voie lactée déjà
immense car il contient 234 milliards de
systèmes solaires autres que le nôtre n'est pas que
une goutte d'eau dans cet immense
Océan
il y a environ cinq milliards d'années dans un
agglomération de météorites errantes dans le
l'espace la présence de rayonnement
l'ultraviolet permet l'apparition de
molécules de glucides essentielles pour
fonctions reproductrices
quand ces météorites et d'eux
les glucides se heurtent aux dieux
planètes où le carbone et l'eau
liquide sont présents la vie apparaît est
pour que certaines formes de vie naissent
quelques planètes de la voie lactée e
probablement sur d'innombrables planètes
autres galaxies
il y a environ un million d'années, le chemin
laiteux anime des êtres semblables à
humains deux fois plus guerriers
Annunaki qui prédomine sur une planète
en orbite autour de l'étoile Nemesys
ils acquièrent beaucoup de technologie
assez avancé pour explorer l'espace
ils parviennent également à pénétrer votre système
solaire colonisant mars et nibiru pour
en faire des stations spatiales nibiru est
une planète qui met 3 600 ans à
faire le tour du
Soleil
au début quand il était attiré par
forces gravitationnelles de notre système
solaire
nibiru est entré en collision avec le
planete t amat et loroupe en deux
[Musique]
générant la terre et la lune son
l'orbite est maintenant stabilisée mais dans
passé
chaque fois que nibiru s'approchait du
la terre a causé un désastre
ses passes ultérieures ont provoqué
les glaciations la fossilisation de
des forêts entières et la disparition des animaux
énorme comme des dinosaures
il y a environ 250 000 ans en raison de
propre orbite qui l'emporte longtemps
météo du soleil
nibiru gèle pour le réchauffer je
Les colons anunnaki créent un effet
serre par pulvérisation d'hélium d'uranium et d'or
dans son ambiance mais nibiru et rare
en or la possibilité d'obtenir plus
se montre quand un roi est au liu
annunaki déposé par nibiru est
réfugié sur terre découvre qu'il y a
d'or en abondance sur cette planète
l'inscription suivante située sur
une tablette sumérienne en témoigne sur
grande montagne de mars qu'ils ont sculptée
avec des rayons l'image de l'aile lui son
face tu regardes toujours vers nibiru où
est arrivé et dans le pays où il est
découvert de l'or
[Musique]
sur mars dans le domaine de cin donia loin dans
effectue une formation montagneuse similaire
à un visage humain
[Musique]
les sumériens sont fiables il y a 5000 ans
ils représentaient déjà toutes les planètes du
notre système solaire incluant uranus
neptune et pluton découverts seulement
il y a quelques décennies
ce n'est pas un hasard si l'un des messages gravés
sur le disque qui accompagnait les sondes
Voyageur américain lancé en 1977
dans l'espace pour contacter tout
civilisations extraterrestres était dans le langage
sumérien
[Musique]
quand le nouveau roi de nibiru anu arrive
sachez qu'il y a de l'or sur terre
prend le commandement d'une expédition
accompagné de ses fils enki et en
lil de certains membres de la famille
réel et par des centaines de scientifiques et moi
militaires ont débarqué dans le sud de
la mésopotamie où il trouve et rit ce qu'il veut
dire à la maison loin de chez soi les tablettes
Les Sumériens citent les Anunnaki comme ceux
qui est venu du ciel sur la terre
ils disent qu'un nu borde le u su
mars et que les anunnaki commencent là
construction des structures nécessaires
à la mission ayant besoin d'eau e
de glucides que les anunnaki réalisent
eden un domaine dédié à l'agriculture
et à l'élevage puis à l'exploration des
la terre entière découvre l'abondance
gisements d'or en afrique du sud
satisfait le vrai quitte le commandement
de la mission terrestre et son héritier
tandis que ceux qui gèrent les mines d'or meurent
au Zimbabwe actuel, mais parfois
après que les explorateurs anunnaki aient utilisé
pour le dur labeur des esclaves
ils refusent de travailler
[Musique]
dans la bible hébraïque écrite certains
millénaire plus tard inspiré par les textes
Les Sumériens loin ne savent pas qui ils s'appellent
élohim et cette rébellion est
représenté par les anges désobéissants
à la demande de dieu
[Musique]
à l'époque des troupeaux d'homo erectus
ils vivaient en afrique australe
les observant et qui comprend que ces
les primates sont adaptés pour creuser la terre
il attrape alors une femelle erectus et le
faire venir le chef de mission de là
[Musique]
l de l'autorisation d'exercer
des expériences
le groupe médical de ne pas à ceux qui manipulent
génétiquement un ovule de cette femelle
le greffer à l'ADN de la femme de la saga mineure
de même il y a environ 200 000 ans
un hybride mâle stérile est né
physiquement fort et intelligent
non qui l'appelle lulu et ne
ils clonent mille qu'ils transportent
petite partie en Eden et en grande partie
dans les mines d'or africaines créées pour
obéir et travailler et lulù intégrer les dieux
concepts existant dans la nature
celle de dieu reconnaissant les capacités
supérieurs du han a qui est-ce
de l'immortalité ne pouvant jamais
constater la mort de la lune qui
car leur durée de vie dépasse
des milliers d'années terrestres excitées et
amusé par cette expérience est le
ordonne à ses médecins de faire des dieux
de nouveaux êtres mêlant l'ADN du lulù
avec celle des autres animaux qu'ils obtiennent
donc fans un être moitié lulu et moitié
chèvre l'anunnaki enseigne
jouer de la flûte d'une jument est né
le centaure moitié juillet et moitié cheval
dont les Anunnaki enseignent l'usage
de l'arc puis créer toutes les créatures
animalier décrit dans les mythologies
[Musique]
le plaisir se termine lorsque ces
les hybrides disparaissent en ne vivant pas plus longtemps que
cent ans comme le 1 en attendant je
les médecins ont un qui ils ont cloné
continuation mais en nombre insuffisant
le travail a duré longtemps
anne qui comprend alors qu'il faut un
lulù fertile capable de procréer sans
plus passer par les laboratoires maelle il
il n'est pas d'accord avec ça
craint une croissance incontrôlée de
ces êtres qui auraient pu
se révolter en faisant dérailler les leurs
mission mais enki rappelle qu'avec
ce nombre limité de lulù a
arrangement la mission serait
définitivement échoué
puis à contrecœur je me retrouve pour
approuver la fécondation du hulu e
l'homme sapiens est produit le
ancêtre de l'annonce actuelle créée par l'homme
image et ressemblance des annonces
c'est une vie parfaite et fructueuse
300 ans et robuste de deux mètres de haut
donc du collecteur d'œufs pacifique et
de légumes que ce primate transmet au
état de l'homme le plus féroce des
chasseurs de terres
[Musique]
cependant l'idée que sapiens et peuvent
être dangereux divise les anunnaki et
neal soutenu par la famille royale dai
militaires qui veulent tous éliminer le
sapiens en faveur du lulù plus
contrôlable également soutenu par
les scientifiques considèrent que le sapiens ben
instruits sont une ressource importante pour
les anunnaki et que dans le futur
et à ces êtres humains nous le devons
quitter le gouvernement de la terre ce
n'empêche pas certains sapiens de
échapper au contrôle du han a che
est de se cacher dans les forêts formant
des tribus nomades mais les sapiens et que
échouer à s'échapper
ai lulù dans les oeuvres d'eden où oui
montrer immédiatement très intéressé par
technologie du nurachi ces ne
ils sont flattés et aiment exposer
leurs connaissances à ces petits êtres
à tête noire ils deviennent alors
une sorte d'homme plus évolué jada doux
[Musique]
les autres sapiens sont plutôt
transporté en Afrique dans les mines
médaille d'or du zimbabwe sous le commandement de
enki enseigne aussi quelques
connaissance supérieure à certains sapiens
mais pour en faire des rois à me confier
ses commandes
les autres sapiens doivent creuser
[Musique]
enki considéré comme un dieu accorde
le titre de prêtre de certains rois ed
établit la première religion la sienne
les règles et l'obéissance totale la menacent
suprême est la mort l'homme est donc
forcé de servir ce dieu impitoyable
pire encore cette cruauté vient
immédiatement imité par les rois qui se considéraient
les privilégiés exploitent les leurs
pouvoir utilisant la violence contre moi
propres sujets
[Musique]
il y a environ 50 000 ans, le riano meurt est là
il n'a pas de temps à perdre s'il veut
conserver le trône était ce que je suis
prétendants sans scrupules et sans scrupules
ne manquez jamais d'effacer la fin
de la mission
[Musique]
maintenant la priorité est de remettre tout le monde debout
nibiru pour défendre son trône enki
qui a un enfant engendré par un
concubine sait qu'elle ne pourra pas accéder au
le trône refuse alors de partir
il a déjà son trône en afrique et
lille s'offusque commande les anunnaki
affecté à l'île de pâques la célèbre
ne jamais garder un œil sur même alors
il sa suite
ils quittent la terre
[Musique]
anne qui ne sait que faire de
tout cet or abandonné en fait don
cadeau aux hommes et à l'âge les plus fidèles
un peu d'or, et il y en a beaucoup
fois depuis le séjour dans les mines
Africain n'est plus nécessaire en qui
il décide de quitter le zimbabwe pour les deux
où est le mieux
lui et sa cour ne donnent pas à qui c'est
ils embarquent ensuite à bord de leur propre
des engins volants suivis sur terre par
rois les plus fidèles et à leurs peuples et aux
première grande migration humaine
de l'afrique au moyen-orient pour
les remercier d'avoir suivi enki avec
siège à chaque fille du roi l'un des
anina chi de sa cour comme époux et
de ces unions naissent des mortels
remarquables sont les dieux héros
cependant adhéré à cette concentration
d'un nurachi et de héros tous les
guerriers est susceptible de se transformer en un
conflit
hanke iman depuis lors les héros dieux un
conquérir les terres occupées par
descendants de sapiens qui ont échappé au leur
Control
[Musique]
les dieux-héros s'en vont donc et certains
ils vont occuper l'egypte et le
d'autres palestiniens envahissent le continent
européenne et éliminer les hommes de
d'autres néandertaliens s'installent
malte et la sardaigne en font
école municipale pour initiés et autres
encore
les dieux s'étendent jusqu'en inde en chine
les héros équipent leurs territoires de
bases d'atterrissage et de lancement
appareil volant gigantesque
bâtiments en pierre où garder le
leurs armes nucléaires et leurs machines publicitaires
énergie sonore en forme de pyramide
visibles du ciel, c'est ainsi qu'ils apparaissent
simultanément et dans différents domaines
du monde le même type de bâtiments
et de la culture à la mort des dieux héros je
leurs trônes passent aux descendants
généré avec des êtres humains formant le
première postérité royale
[Musique]
il y a environ 12 000 ans, la flotte spatiale
d'emil devenu roi de nibiru revient
sur terre pour éliminer ces humains
qu'il avait contre son gré
autorisé à naître également concerné
essaie de communiquer avec son frère mais
la réponse est un rayon destructeur qui
accidents entre le courant au maroc et
Espagne
[Musique]
un bruit terrifiant la terre qui
l'afrique liée à l'europe se désintègre
dans les airs et l'océan Atlantique oui
se déverse comme une fureur à travers elle
détroit de gibraltar nouvellement créé comme
une énorme canonnade d'eau les vagues
ils pénètrent dans la Méditerranée en détruisant
écoles d'initiation à malte et à
la sardaigne puis submerge l'italie et la
séparé de la tunisie inonde le
La Grèce le remplit d'îles et ils pénètrent
entre la bulgarie et la turquie formant le
mer Noire
enfin des vagues de 50 mètres de haut oui
ils dirigent vers et balayent tout vers
leur passage
[Musique]
appelé déluge mondial par la bible
cette catastrophe ne touche pas vraiment ça
la zone située entre la Méditerranée et
mésopotamie
anne qui parvient tout de même à prévenir le
lire amita fermant le nom biblique qui
construit une arche pour s'y réfugier
la famille et ses animaux lorsque le
l'inondation se termine l'arche s'échoue
dans la vision arménienne actuelle va transpirer et le
sa famille sort alors ed
s'accoupler avec les quelques survivants
réfugiés dans les montagnes, ils repeuplent les
monde oubliant ses origines
ces personnes sont regroupées dans l'ancien
les agglomérations urbaines cultivent la terre
élever des animaux vivre en harmonie
avec la nature et organiser une société
sans hiérarchies et sans discrimination
sexuelle avec le cadeau en règle générale pour
entreprendre des échanges
el il remarque ces quelques humains
survécu mais quand enki se jette je
ses pieds
triomphe et s'estime satisfait de la
situation mais est lille n'est pas revenu dans le
système solaire et seulement pour punir
les humains doivent aussi évacuer mars
devenu inutile puis recommence avec le
son escorte est redevenue maîtresse
de la terre aussi sa cour d'un
nurachi capture des survivants humains
les utiliser comme main-d'œuvre pour
réparation des dommages subis par rido e
d'eden et partager ce que
reste des territoires a émergé le premier un
émouvant est le fils d'enki marduk qui
soumet le peuple tunisien jusqu'à ce
south anna et les regroupe en constituant le
peuple des Egyptiens
son domaine comprend les pyramides
construit plus tôt par les dieux et les héros
lui pousse un énorme lion de pierre qui
marduk l'a modifié pour lui donner le visage
de son fils nabu ma murdoch a è
expulsé d'égypte et retourne en
Mésopotamie où il fonda Babylone
al trianon aki les frères dan rama e
vira occupe la scandinavie mais plus tard
ils l'abandonnent rarement pour chercher un climat
plus tempérés et ils se séparent
[Musique]
dan et sa cohorte humaine vont à
occuper la sardaigne rama arrive en
l'Inde mais une race noire très évoluée lo
forcé de se replier en Anatolie où
constitue le peuple indo-européen
troisième frère vire vers lo
détroit de bering et entre en amérique la
côtes et arrive avec sa cour dans
colombie où il a fondé la civilisation andine la
lune kim hwang a appelé l'empereur
le jaune occupe la plaine de pékin ed
envahit les peuples voisins en fondant
les jeunes de la chine ancienne ont une clé
protégé par murdoch occupe la palestine
et détruit les villes de Sodome et de
gomorrhe
qui refusent de passer sous son
domaine
j'avais un ami humain abraham et ça
l'amitié les conduit à un pacte de
l'alliance l'avait promis à Abraham et
à ses descendants qui leur donneront le
terre de canaan en retour nous jurerions
adorer aiab est comme dieu
célibataire et être circoncis lui et ai
ses fils pour se distinguer de
hommes d'autres factions
dans le récit biblique l'un des fils
d'Abraham Ismaël est l'ancêtre de
tribus islamiques tandis que le petit-fils de
abraham jacob est l'ancêtre des tribus
d'Israël
[Musique]
un problème se pose en eden quand en
qui engendre des enfants avec deux femelles
l'homme est là sur mars
mais quand il apprend que même un
noble même à son frère enki
rejoint avec l'homme devient fou
de colère est une honte pour lui combien
l'union sexuelle d'un homme est aujourd'hui
avec un animal il ordonne alors de chasser
tous les humains d'eden dans la bible et
l'expulsion du paradis terrestre
[Musique]
ces personnes partent ensuite et vont à
s'installer vers le golfe Persique
entre le Tigre et l'Euphrate où
ils ont fondé une cinquantaine de petits royaumes
formant le peuple sumérien à respecter
aux humains primitifs qui habitent ces
terres
les nouveaux arrivants viennent avec un
héritage technologique très avancé de
leur passé dans l'Eden les Sumériens
ils connaissent le système solaire ils inventent le
calendrier en divisant la journée en 24 heures
et l'heure que les 60 minutes calculent
compliqué dans l'ingénierie et le travail
équations algébriques du troisième degré
ainsi qu'exceller dans toutes les sciences
ils inventent aussi l'école pour
éducation et écriture par gaufrage
sur des tablettes de type argile
cunéiformes représentant
expressions phonétiques du mot est
pour que les Sumériens écrivent les leurs
histoires de vie et leurs connaissances
en précisant qu'ils ne sont pas moi
détenteurs du maillage des connaissances scientifiques
je ne sais pas qui
[Musique]
pendant ce temps une émeute éclate
nibiru
Je suis toujours sur Mars
mais la laisse de si mauvaise humeur que
quand il tombe sur un virus, il se tache
d'autant d'iniquités que la sienne
la famille royale le contraint à l'exil
chez ceux qui sont ensuite rappelés d'urgence
su nibiru comme héritier du trône
[Musique]
celui qui veut laisser aux hommes le
gestion foncière à letta gli
anunnaki dispersés à travers le monde
promettant que s'ils le suivent, il divisera
avec eux le pouvoir de retrait donc sur
Il y a 5000 ans, les anunnaki quittent le
atterrir les annotations sur simple et terminer
d'ailleurs à cette date
[Musique]
à cette même date la préhistoire
se termine et l'histoire débute cependant dans
1849 et à Ninive
si les archéologues n'avaient pas découvert
ces milliers de tablettes sumériennes qui
ils mentionnent nos ancêtres comme les
produit d'une manipulation génétique
entre un primate et un non-extraterrestre
nous en saurions beaucoup sur l'origine
de l'espèce humaine
si ce que les Sumériens ont écrit est
c'est vrai que cela explique le manque de
découvertes qui prouvent l'évolution
Théorie darwinienne de l'homme et des grands
la pierre travaille que notre technologie
d'aujourd'hui ne peut pas correspondre si cela ne correspond pas
Il est vrai
félicitations les plus chaleureuses à la fantaisie
de ces Sumériens il y a 5000 ans ont
a inventé cette histoire fantastique
[Applaudissements]